[Music]
when an artist feels that they want to
write about whether that's dancing
or or just looking good or just feeling
good about yourself or you want to write
about atrocity or you want to write
advice about poverty or you want to
write about the difficulties of your day
to day or the joys of your day to day at
least be [ __ ] honest about it we all
sign an unwritten social contract in it
in a society I think we all have
somewhat of a responsibility to at least
be aware to as best we can of issues no
matter talk about them when we can
[Music]
change doesn't happen yeah out of the
good graces or the good conscience of
politicians we like to remember it that
way but it didn't really isn't
introduced in the case protesters is
often vilified as this sort of
disruptive disruption for its own sake
and that it's often smeared or vilified
is like you know intentionally
disruptive but even in the sixties and
even back then it's always you know this
is disruption for disruption sake you
push
what's nice to remind people it's just
that like Power has never conceded
anything without without demand but all
progress that's ever been made it comes
at the at the expense sometimes
frustrating people if needs be that is
exerting pressure about an
institutionalized power it's some of the
traditions that I kind of write music in
so like in a kind of rock and roll
tradition in the folk tradition well
certainly the rock and roll tradition I
see it actually less less than that's
obviously punk rock has always been has
always been punk rock Bush I think a lot
of a lot of protest music is happening
you know more and more someone on the
hip-hop side things I suppose
I think Kendrick Kendrick and in a lot
of ways kind of open my eyes to that and
somewhat certainly with the typical
butterfly that was just yeah it's really
really an outrageously honest honest and
lyrics kind of been being banned in that
and just there's a there's a there's a
real there's a real bravery to that in a
real kind of great admiration for it
force